welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
turning to No Country F all
men so when doing our big breakdown of
the movie I got into deep diving on a
number of videos and articles on the
film one that stuck out to me was by
what is anti logic who did a fantastic
video breaking down their theories on
the movie I touched upon it in our video
but since making it it's something
that's stuck with me I think there's a
lot of factors in it that I really want
to touch upon and and it's taken me off
in a certain direction that's made me
realize one thing that is that suar
isn't real what throughout this video
yeah we're going to be talking about the
evidence to support that and what we
think is actually going on without the
way huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into No Country for all men
the coin don't have no
say it's just you okay so what is anti
logic theorize that moss and CH girl are
actually the same person they thought
that the movie had a sort of f Club
Motif in in which their two
personalities imagining things play out
the pair never interact they never talk
to each other and yet throughout the
film they share a lot of actions both
sit down on the couch in Moss's trailer
looking at the TV we see them drinking
they also both remove their socks at one
point and both their weapons are similar
they both buy clothes from strangers in
the movie and so on and so forth the the
eyes that Moss went out that night to
give the water to the guy because Shar
knew he had to meet with a businessman
at the side of the deal gone wrong I
love that theory and though I don't NE
necessarily think that them being the
same person is what I take from it I
think that there are very interesting
elements there it's with this in mind
that I studied it out whether Sho was
actually real and when going back
through the film I think that he is in
fact something else that takes us in a
few time few time the time of my life
and I owe it all to you now in order to
explain this we have to look at the book
in itself for context every chapter in
it's opened by the narration of sheriff
Bell which itself is mer in the opening
of the movie I always like to hear about
the oldtimers can't help but wonder how
they'd operate at these times he begins
by telling us the stories of old
sheriffs and also some strange cases
that he's come across before this
includes a child abduction that he just
can't get his head around and lastly
ends there by saying this the crime you
see now it's hard to even take its
measure so this is very much his story
as he's the only Survivor out of the
quote unquote good guys now I I don't
think he knows Sho well enough to
actually include him properly this story
is because the pair never meet though
they are what you'd class as the hero
and villain characters at no point do
they ever come face to face it's a
strange thing that people often
criticize the movie for well they don't
criticize it but they bring it up and
that's because the pair both bit the
archetypes of a classic Western you see
back in the day kids Heroes would wear
white hats and the villains would DP
black that's the case with it here too
and it's all done a place them at
opposite ends of the spectrum now
looking at your he pretty much kills
everyone that he comes across except
except for a few select characters
picked up by the policeman at the start
he ends up strangling him before then
stealing a car from someone unlucky
enough to cross his path the gas
attendant lucky enough to live and the
woman at the trailer is saved by a
toilet
flush aier he then ends up killing the
businessmen and then the cartel members
at the motel he then kills the checking
guy at the hotel Carson Wells the
chicken coup truck owner the guy who
hired him and lastly colagene so there's
very few people that encounter him that
live to tell the tale and this was in a
time before CCTV now in the latter part
of the film The two people who might be
able to place him there are either
scared into not talking or they're just
bored out are you going to shoot me that
depends do you see me take it
in you didn't see me I was already gone
so there's a high possibility that
sherff Bell wouldn't even get a
description of him or any idea of what
the villain of his story looked like now
going back to the these first two people
that encountered him there's a low
possibility that they would talk to B
either the gas station guy likely was in
question because the police would have
no way to truck the burned out cars
Journey back to the station ask him that
means that he would have had to report
the crime himself which is still
something you can argue whether would
have happened even if he had have though
it would have been that there was just a
guy acting weird from earlier in the day
which Bell might not have put together
with the crimes the second woman would
be someone that we would know would have
been asked at some point in the film but
he never brings her up or uses her as a
way to lead to Moss so let's just scrap
them as being people that would talk to
cuz cuz this kind of theory it does kind
of hinge on that so to me no only seear
would end up giving that information
back to Bell or the ones that would
wouldn't do it out of fear of
Retribution or because they were given
money to keep quiet now beyond that we
also see how Shar moves throughout the
film even when he's walking around with
a massive gun no one really sees him or
pays attention to him Shar even blows up
a car at Mike sau's Pharmacy for a
distraction that keep keeps the
attention locked solely on that as he
walks in no one looks at him no one pays
attention and in many ways he's just
like a ghost now the key evidence that
CH girl is just a figment of Bell's
imagination comes at the motel in what
would normally be the final showdown
approaching the motel room we see Belle
looking at a blown-off lock and can
clearly catch someone in the reflection
of it if you stare at it long enough
that definitely looks like she girl and
into cut with this are the scenes of him
standing behind the door however when
Bell opens it up nobody is there and the
room's completely empty this highlights
to me that shagar was never real and
rather he acted as a manifestation of
all of Bell's ideas about what the face
of evil was the entire movie is
basically about him realizing that he's
not it out for this new reality in which
Psychopaths run rampant and kill for
pleasure the Know Country for Old Men
that is about him and he often Ponders
how the oldtimers would have handled
modern day some of the old time
Sheriff's never read more gun in the end
B retires because he realizes he's not
good out to catch men like shigar which
is how he got away that he never
encounters him and this in the end had
to create this character for his story
this is also highlighted to us in the
film when we hear him discussing this
you know Charlie Waller's got that place
out east of Sanderson this is involving
a story about a farmer who used a Bulan
to kill cattle but it ended up
ricocheting and hitting him in the Sher
later on when colag asks about them he
says was that a true story about Charlie
waler who's Charlie wer to me this shows
he likes to spin a tail in the moment
but doesn't really hold much attachment
to it because he knows it's not real
that story of course has a bulon being
used as a weapon and who else uses a
bulun as a weapon that's right sugar you
son of a I believe that Bell
brought this across from his story about
the farmer because that's just the
weapon that was on his mind at the time
the movie is simply Bell retelling a
story that led to his retirement but the
specifics of it are where things get
hazy we never see what happens with a
drug deal gone wrong I never see how
Moss gets killed the fact is B knows the
setting that stuff went down at but not
the specifics which is why he skips over
it instead I think Shar is an urban
legend type figure who's been invented
by Belle to explain the actions of
either the cartel or bounty hunters
hunting him making them one person
simplifies the story and gives it its
villain but in reality he never existed
however the public audience and even B
himself they all need someone they can
point the finger at that is the killer
who got away and escape the grasp of the
law never to be seen again this ghost
acts as a far better story and we can
even look at our own history in order to
support this that comes in the form of
Jack the repper who's arguably the most
famous serial killer of all time
countless stories exist about him and
these range from Comics to TV shows
Games movies stage plays and more the
riper was never caught and because of
this there's been a number of theories
about his identity people have believed
he was the Royal Physician covering up
the my deats of the crown the prince
himself lowly doctors Beggars and so on
we will never have conclusive proof and
there's even some who suspect that the
riper was more than one man that's
because crimes like that had been
perpetrated in White Chapel before there
was no forensic evidence to conclusively
link the crimes and there was also the
possibility of there being copycat it's
not completely out the question that
there were several Murders At The Ripper
figure didn't carry out but the legend
makes it easier to put them all under
the same Monica the name Shar also comes
from the Spanish word segua which means
to follow thus there is a possibility
that even that was created by Sheriff
beld but a person to these evil Deeds
out rocked his County Shar is a
boogeyman type figure along the lines of
Michael Myers or even death himself in
the story he never shows any emotion
doesn't seem to have any real wants of
goals but beyond getting the money and
disappears mysteriously to never be seen
again he also says that he comes with a
coin on the same Journey that it did I
got here the same way the coin indeed
this in the end I think what we are
looking at isn't a person per se and
instead we are seeing B trying to
comprehend the horror he witnessed in
his mind he's still dealing in black and
white rather than the wickedness that
the world's now faced with it's easier
to make a grim repaper type figure to
explain this and the Shar fits the mole
for the story shagar is a monster death
personified who comes in and disappears
without leaving any trace of himself
there's no one to say they saw him most
of the people left in his wake are dead
and in the end no one ever really
encounters him thus to me Shar is just a
ghost and in the end he didn't really
exist at least I think obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it so make
sure you drop them below and also check
out what is anti logic's video as it's
it's really worth watching they're
quickly becoming one of my favorite
channels and also thanks to all you guys
who told me I should watch them please
drop a like on the video and if you want
to support the channel as a member of
the spoiler Society then please click
the join button we're trying to do it
for as cheap as possible we don't want
anyone breaking the bank it's just 99
cents a month or 99 P very much a sort
of give what you can but in exchange for
that you'll get early access to videos
every week the No Country FAL men one
that went out a week early for members
Back to the Future 3 all that so yeah if
you like these videos then it's
definitely worth supporting if you want
to get some heavy spoilers merch like
our the time one which we did this whole
video on then that will be linked in the
description below as well we got
Marvel's on there House of dragon stuff
and yeah thank you everyone who's bought
one and supported us you some else to
watch our big breakdowns on screen right
now so definitely head over there right
after this by the way huge thank you for
sting through the video I've been your
host Paul I'll see you next time you
take care peace